السعوديه تعلن ايداع مليار دولار في حساب
البنك المركزي اليمني خبر فور اعلالي سجل
الريال اليمن ارتفاعا كبيرا امام العملات
الاجنبيه في اطار مسانده الشعب اليمني
تنمويا واقتصاديا وتعزيز قدرات البلاد في
برنامج الاصلاح الاقتصادي مع صندوق النقد
العربي كاجهه فنيه نحن نثمن ونقدر اصول
الوديعه ونقول فعلا الوديعه سوف تاتي
اكلها وتحقق نتائج على مستوى الصرف وعلى
مستوى الاقتصاد اذا ماتت خطوات متكامله
دائما نتمنى
انهم يساعدونا في ايش
دعم اقتصاد ولكن نقولها ونكرر انه دعم
الاقتصاد لا يمكن يترتب وصول مذيعه فقط
نحتاج الى اخراج القطاع المصرفي من سباته
من جهته اعرب مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني
شكره للسعوديه واكد ان الوديعه تمثل دفعه
قويه للاقتصاد اليماني
والتخفيف من وطاه الازمه الانسانيه
الحكومه اليمنيه وصفت الوديعه السعودي
بالخطوه الكبيره والمهمه التي ستسهم في
تحسين السياسه النقديه للبنك المركزي
وتحقيق استقرار العمله
هذا الوديعه ليست الاولى سوف تسم بشكل
كبير جدا في تحسن الوضع الاقتصادي وخصوصا
مع قدوم شهر رمضان المبارك والذي داء
غالبا ما يستغله كثير من التجار في رفع
الاسعار وفي مضاعفه معاناه المواطنين هذه
الوديعه سوف تسهم بشكل كبير جدا في خلق
استقرار اقتصادي ولكن نتمنى من الحكومه
اليمنيه انها تعمل على عمل رقابه على
الاسواق وعلى التجار
وعلى مستوى الشارع اليمني عاد منسوب
التفاؤل بتحسين الوضع الاقتصادي والمعيشي
بفعل استقرار سعر العمله اليمنيه التي
كانت تشهد تراجعا كبيرا حتى قبيل الساعات
طبعا ستكون اثر كبير في حياه المواطن
الحياه الباطل العام في حياه في عيشه ضنكا
نتيجه الارتفاع الاسعار نتمنى ان تكون هذا
الوديع عامل محفز للاقتصاد الاقتصاد
اليمني في المحافظات المحرره يواصل الريال
اليمني رفع قيمته امام مدفوع بالوديعه
السعوديه التي اجمعت الاوساط السياسيه
والاقتصاديه هنا ان اثرها سيكون كبيرا في
انقاذ اقتصاد البلاد والتخفيف من معاناه
المواطن ردفان دبيس العربيه عدن